Olá minhas amigas meus amigos para mais
uma live estamos juntos aqui para falar
de alguns assuntos e depois responder as
dúvidas de
vocês boa noite Adriana Boa noite Eliane
Denise
Leopoldino
bem pessoal tava aqui respondendo uma
mensagem aqui mas vamos
começar muito bem Tem um estudo
interessante uma
metanálise que foi
observado como é que se comportava os
níveis de homocisteína e vitamina B12 em
pacientes exportadores de
[Música]
Parkinson Esse é um dos artigos que a
gente vai discutir hoje
aqui então nessa metanálise os
participantes com doença de paxon
apresentaram níveis mais alos de
homocisteína e níveis mais baixos
vitamina B12 e ácido fólico em
comparação com os controles
saudáveis então nós sabemos que o índice
de homocisteína no sangue é hiper
homocisteina pode aumentar a produção de
radicais livres e tem sido proposto como
fator contribuinte no início ou da
progressão da doença de parson Fora as
outras doenças né Doença de Alzheimer
AVC infarto
osteoporose câncer ão várias doenças
associadas AOC na alta então nós sabemos
que vitamina B2 e o ácido fólico são
essenciais para metabolismo da cisteína
e a deficiência desses nutrientes podem
contribuir para uma cisteína alta Então
esse estudo foram analisados adultos com
e sem doença de
paxon foram
participantes sendo que em 4000 foram
analizadas a B12
3600 o f
e no total dos participantes também foi
analisado homocisteína
então a metanálise incluiu 71 estudos
caso controle ou transversais nos quais
foram avaliados os níveis de hosena B2
folato em participantes com D paxon e
sem e também outros que não tinham
doença ou histórico de outros problemas
neurológicos Então essa comparação
analisou o papel do comprometimento
cognitivo neuropatia periférica statatus
de
tratamento como não tratado ou recebendo
inibidores da catecol ome metil
transferase ess ex muito importante na
produção de
neurotransmissores Então quais foram os
resultados então no geral os participan
com paxon tiveram níveis mais altos de
homocisteína e níveis mais baixos de B12
folato comparação com os participantes
controle
Ah eu esqueci de perguntar para vocês
como é que está o áudio me dê por favor
o feedback do
áudio os níveis de Hina foram mais altos
entes participantes com doença de paxão
não tratada ou tratado com inibidores do
cont
um em comparação com os participantes do
controle então entre os participantes
com paxon ter comprometimento cognitivo
foi associado a níveis mais altos de tem
em comparação como não ter
comprometimento cognitivo e ter
neuropatia periférica foi associado a
níveis mais altos de homocisteína em
comparação com não ter neuropatia
periférica e os níveis de homocisteína
também foram mais altos entre os homens
com paxo em comparação com as mulheres e
essa tendência também foi observada em
populações
Gerais a B12 foi mais baixa entre os
participantes com doença de paxo não
tratado
ou tratado com inibidores da conte em
comparação com os participantes do
controles e a B2 também foi mais baixa
entre os participantes com paxon e
comprometimento cognitivo ou neuropatia
periférica em comparação a aquele 100s
paxo os níveis de folato foram mais
baixo entre os participantes não
tratados com des de paxo em comparação
com os participantes controle e também
foram mais baixos entre os participantes
com comprom comento cognitivo em
comparação com aqueles sem
comprometimento
cognitivo então e esse estudo tá
mostrando claramente que a homocisteína
é uma cadur importante para uma doença
neurodegenerativa você tem que monitorar
homocisteína B12 e ácido fólico nesses
pacientes e pacientes em geral que eu
acompanho já monitoro tudo isso
daí o próximo estudo é
se alguns suplementos nutricionais
contendo eprin soro de leite e vitamina
D se ou não Aumentou a massa muscular
dos membros superiores e inferiores em
adultos mais velhos que tinham
sarcopenia eles analisaram isso o protem
vitamina D se ajudou isso a aumentar a
massa
muscular então foram 715 adultos idosos
com idade entre 68 e 85 e todos eles
tinham sarcopenia que é deficiência de
massa muscular Esse estudo também foi a
metanálise juntou seis estudos
anteriores
randomizados em cinco estudos os
participantes tomaram de 10 a 40 g de
proteína de whei diariamente com ou sem
aminoácidos adicionados vitamina D ou
outras vitaminas e minerais enquanto em
um estudo os participantes tomaram
suplemento contendo leucina arginina
vitamina D glicosamina e cálcio o grupo
de comparação o controle recebeu Placebo
então em cinco dos seis ensaios os
participantes também fizeram exercícios
associado à suplementação a duração da
intervenção foi em geral 12 semanas a
composição corporal foi avaliada através
do método padrão ouro que é o Dex Scan
que é um tipo de distometria
especial e o desempenho funcional foi
avaliado usando um tipo de questionário
de performance uma bateria de
performance física curta Então os
resultados comparado ao Placebo o grupo
de intervenção Aumentou a massa muscular
dos membros em pequena medida mas não
teve efeito na força de preensão manual
nem no desempenho funcional então houve
aumento de massa mas Aparentemente a
força não
acompanhou o risco de ter viés né de ter
algum tipo de direcionamento no estudo
foi incerto em Quatro ensaios e alto em
dois
ensaios
Então esse estudo mostrou que sim
vitamina D O Protein não ajudou a ganhar
esforço força muscular mas ajudou na
massa próximo estudo foi para analisar
se o consumo de chá verde foi não
associado a uma taxa de envelhecimento
biológico
menor foram 13.000 quase 14.000
participantes com entre 30 e 80
anos a maioria dos participantes era da
China idade mediana de 51 anos 62% de
mulheres 38% de homens e teve também um
pessoal da grater do Reino
Unido então análise utilizou dados de
dois estudos prospectivos de cort para
determinar se o consumo de chá estava
associado ou não à velocidade de
envelhecimento biológico e o período de
acompanhamento foi de 2 e 4,5 anos nos
estudos forão dois estudos o chinês e o
inglês o consumo de chá foi avaliado no
início no acompanhamento por meio de
questionários esses dados foram
utilizados para dividir os participantes
em quatro categorias com base nos os de
consumo de chá não consumidor
consistente consumidor ocasional e
consumidor
consistente então a estimativa de
aceleração da idade biológica foi
calculado usando biomarcadores clínicos
antropométricos foram selecionados
biomarcadores com base em sua correlação
com a idade cronológica então foram
selecionad 15 num estudo e 18 no outro
de
biomarcadores incluiu mas não se
limitando a pressão arterial relação
cintura quadril enzimas hepáticas
Albumina hemoglobina glicada e
tribos os resultados foram ajustados
para vários fatores de confusão
potenciais como sexo raça etnia estatus
socioeconômico e tabagismo consumo de
álcool fatores dietéticos atividade
física índice massa corporal e histórico
de doenças e quais foram os resultados
em comparação com os não consumidores de
chá o consumo consistente de qualquer
quantidade de chá incluindo mais de oit
xícaras por dia foi sim associado ao
envelhecimento biológico mais lento a
maior redução na velocidade de
envelhecimento biológico foi observado
com uma dose de duas a três xícaras de
chá verde por dia que equivale a 6 a 8 g
de
folhas interessante isso tudo né então
chá verde pode tá te ajudando a
envelhecer mais lentamente tá eles
sempre dizem né que os resultados podem
devem ser interpretados com
cautela porque foi tirado estudos
observacionais
tá então tem que ficar um pouco atento
quanto a
isso
eh Denise eu não estou gostando muito do
áudio estou escutando mas acho que tá um
pouco estranho eu tô um pouco fanho
também tá não sei se é
isso isso eu tô eu tô com o nariz meio
entupido Denise mas fora isso o áudio tá
bom o volume do áudio tá bom porque eu
tô fanho mesmo tá eu comecei uma gripe A
quinta-feira tô me recuperando mais hoje
aí tá vamos lá então bem Vamos responder
as perguntas que vocês deixaram no
documento Vou compartilhar a tela
aqui deixa eu voltar aqui
p eu tava vendo as perguntas antes vou
voltar aqui paraa primeira
pergunta
bem vamos
lá deixa eu compartilhar
aqui bem deixa eu saar a
tela
Pera aí que
pronto primeira pergunta Carlos kman foi
postado um vídeo no grupo que garante
será casca de limão ralada inúmeras
vezes melhor que suco principalmente na
prevenção de câncer Esse vídeo foi
produzido pela Bacharel e cientista
Conceição ela fala muitas coisas em
outros vídeos como por exemplo de que
não existe vinagre de maçã Tod são
falsificados isso é esquisito no mínimo
né e não recomenda o que eu acho uma
piada é não vi o vídeo dela mas é bem
esquisito essa afirmação
mesmo na sua opinião ou em base em
estudos o assunto de casca de limão
merece atenção de modo geral viu Carlos
qualquer alimento vegetal a concentração
na casca vai ser maior do que o sumo
nas frutas é muito comum isso aí tá você
vai ter mais quercetina na casca da maçã
do que na parte central então muitas
frutas Isso é verdade que a casca tem
maior
concentração de bioativos no caso a
casca de limão tem maior
concentração de vitamina C flavonoides
limoneno
pectina tá vai ter um efeito
anticancerígeno maior vai masó sozinho
vai ter um efeito poderoso não poderoso
não vai ter
sozinho tá tem estudos em animais
cultura de células mostrando que
compostos como limoneno que estão na
casca do Limão podem inibir o
crescimento de células cancerosas Mas
isso é inv vitro em animal e Geralmente
as doses que eles usam em animais são
doses
cavalares certo então tem que tomar
cuidado com essas
afirmações
Boa noite Eliseu miram Denise Carlos
Antônio Renato Pedro Luis betete benete
Leopoldino todos vocês sejam muito
bem-vindos bem vamos lá vamos pra
próxima
pergunta Desculpem a minha voz
fanha Nila gostaria de saber um pouco
mais sobre dengue chicungunha o que tem
Tornado esses vírus tão resistentes
Vamos responder isso em etapas
né Tem vários fatores de proteínas
virais
ns1 também a carga viral o sóti o
genótipo fatores aí
do hospedeiro do do da pessoa doente
como pessoas que já tiveram contato com
o vírus da dengue ou da chicungunha pode
desenvolver uma condição chamado aumento
dependente de anticorpos Às vezes o fato
de ter mais anticorpos e torna até maior
o risco de piorar e desenvolver uma
dengue hemorrágica Então existe essa
condição que a imunidade Nem sempre é
protetora às vezes ela pode piorar a
situação Porque deixa a pessoa
hiperativa o vírus tem fatores
ambientais como mudança de clima Então
esse é complexo
Ok no caso chicungunha existe mutações
virais que aumentam a transmissão e o
potencial
[Música]
epidêmico e também a falta de imunidade
de rebanho em populações que foram
recentemente expostas ao vírus
Tá
então não existe antivirais específicos
nem para dengue nem para chicungunha a
vitamina D tem alguma atividade
antiviral aquele protocolo que eu uso
para
e covid pode ajudar bastante aqui
vitamina C vitamina D que cetina zinco
Então tem um protocolo que eu uso para
viroses e que funciona bem para covid
que pode funciona bem também para
chicungunha e para
dengue Além disso elderberry né que é o
Salgueiro a curcumina né a própria casca
de limão que nós comentamos aqui pode
ter alguma ação viral também então Faria
esse tratamento conjunto tá NSA se você
estiver ao vivo
acompanhando me diga se isso foi o
suficiente ou se você ainda tem dúvidas
a respeito disso
aí Boa noite a Marta Almeida aí a Nilsa
tá aqui ela está Eu acho que a mesma
Nilsa né Não sei se Nilsa Cardoso e
Nilsa Rocha a mesma pessoa
é É sim deve ser a mesma
pessoa bem vamos paraa
próxima
Eliane água com hidrogênio molecular
Quais são os reais benefícios o
principal
benefício É de
fato a questão
antioxidante vários estudos mostram que
água hidrogenada tem propriedades
antioxidantes interessantes pode ajudar
a reduzir o stresso oxidativo inflamação
e também hidrogênio molecular entregue
através de inalação aí hoje tá ficando
cada vez Popular tem estudos mostrando
também melhora de performance
atlética reduzindo fadiga inflamação
muscular tem estudo mostrando que é
efeito interessante anti efeitos
colaterais de
radioterapia um estudo pequeno de
pacientes com câncer de fígado em que
água hidrogenada reduziu esses
efeitos efeitos também benéficos
neurológicos mas aí estão estudos de
animais que mostrou que ága hidrogenada
poderia ter efeitos
protetores para condições como
paxon mas ainda não tem estudos em
humanos que eu
saiba Tá hidrogenada ou hidrogênio
molecular
inalado é interessante sim mas
precisamos de mais estudos tá eu
inclusive considerei comprar o
equipamento aqui pra clínica mas eu tô
esperando essa coisa
consolidar um Pou
mais vamos pra
próxima obrigado pelo
feedback pela
resposta Eliseu Live quinta-feira eu vou
fazer uma live Essa quinta Eliseu
sozinho falando sobre dmso tá bom essa
aqui é o assunto dmso
Francisco Weber Doutor uso de roso
vastatina efetivamente traz alguma
melhora na redução do colesterol Sim ela
é efetiva para isso para reduzir
colesterol e
triglicérides eu tenho utilizado
Francisco doses baixas de rosuvastatina
junto com extin
inositol e tenho tido ótimos resultados
porque aí eu tenho um efeito
positivo ros vastatina sem um efeito
colateral qual ser o efeito colateral
fadiga muscular dor
muscular queda
cognitiva Então até toxicidade no
fígado algumas pessoas também têm além
de dor muscular pode ter náusea vômito
dor de cabeça dor
abdominal tá e então Esso estratégia é
muito boa e quem me chamou atenção para
isso foi o Dr Artur Lemos e hoje eu
comecei a fazer uso de ros vastatina em
vez de usar 20 MG usando CCO e tem tido
um excelente resultado não tem tido
problema de efeito colateral só que aí
eu associo exato deosol para ter a
melhor efeito aí de baixar triglicérides
aumentar H colesterol que é o principal
que eu quero
Ok próxima pergunta
vamos pra
próxima
Lívia ela mandou uma pergunt Ona aqui
que tá assim meio que parecendo pedido
de consulta mas eu vou responder
tá tá ela tá falando que o filho tem
Hashimoto tem o nódulo de tireode
o celenio estava a 40 em outubro e ou do
75 tem que ver desse laboratório Qual
que é o valor de selenio que eles
consideram baixo ou alto tá Elen não é
um exame que seja igual de um
laboratório pro
outro eu falo em vídeo sobre equilíbrio
dos dois suplemento sim importante no
material de referência encontrou uma
sugestão de valores de 200 microg sim
selênio 100 Ok eu deto 400 sim é uma
dose bem segura essa daqui passem por
dois médicos integrativos em Campinas a
prisão deles foi bem diferente primeiro
prescreveu o celenio 600 é muito tá eu
não usaria essa dose já tem risco de
intoxicação e nada de
odo não tem que usar os dois o segundo
prescreveu celenio 100 e kelp e odine
200 aí tá correto porque o segundo Fe tá
errado
correto fiquei perdida Porque para mim
parece uma diferença muito grande Sim
mas não é tão dispare assim eu acho que
tá o que tá mais dispare que esse cend
tá a sua prescrição no material de
referência vale para qualquer resultado
Lógico que não pessoal tem que ver eh
individualizar né isso tem que ser
individualizado o que eu passei foi uma
dose segura paraa maioria das pessoas
faz sentido alguma das prescrições acima
pela lógica do
equilíbrio Então eu não sei de cabeça o
valor de selênio desse
laboratório não sei se tá muito baixo
aqui teria que tá vendo o próprio
referência do laboratório mas eu não
posso fazer isso isso aqui não é para
consulta Pessoal esse serviço
que de lives semanais de material isso
tudo é para educação não é para
consultas particulares vocês sabem disso
né mas eu acho que a conduta do segundo
foi mais consistente do segundo médico
Você está acompanhando ao vivo Olívia se
tiver acompanhando me dê um alô aí
OK pro próximo Pedro Por que que o meu
teste testosterone é alta no sangue
limite superior no na saliva está no
limite
inferior
tá provavelmente o que tá
acontecendo é o quê a testosterona no
sangue reflete a produção do seu corpo
se você tiver usando testosterona gel
não sei se você tá usando gel ou
injeção que forma você tá fazando de
reposição ou se tá ou não tá repondo mas
a que você tá medindo no sangue ela
reflete a produção total e se você tiver
tomando injeção também reflete isso e
seja
usando por
exemplo sublingual também reflete agora
se tiver usando transdérmico a do sangue
não vai tá
refletindo a reposição transdérmica A
não ser que a dose da transdérmica seja
muito alta agora quando você mede a
testosterona saliva isso reflete a
quantidade de testosterona biodisponível
está de fato embebida nos
tecidos a a quantidade de testosterona
que está livre Ok
Ativa é possível ter produção alta tá
produzindo ou recebendo testosterona
injetável por exemplo mas ela pode estar
mesmo assim com biodisponibilidade baixa
como você pode també abg muito ácido por
exemplo tá segurando testosterona que é
proteína carreadora você pode estar com
problemas da Albumina também que tá
segurando a
testosterona então quanto mais esse hbg
tiver ou se ess esse hbg tiver alto o
ácido ele pode segurar demais a
testosterona e não deixar a testosterona
livre
entende outra pó situação possível é que
essa testosterone esteja sendo
convertida em di do testosterone DHT e
não tá tendo tanto testosterona livre na
saliva porque foi convertido em D
ter tem a questão também dos valores
podem flutuar ao longo do dia às vezes
você mediu o sangue de manhã que tem o
Pico e mediu a saliva outro horário aí
pode ter feito essa distorção
também
certo não sei se eu respondi o que você
queria ouvir agora alta quanto eu não
sei quanto é que tá o quanto tá
considerando alto né Se for limite
superior da referência não é alto tá não
é alto eu não me preocuparia Agora tem
que ver os efeitos colaterais tá tendo
acne tá tendo irritabilidade tá tendo
calvice tá tendo excesso de glóbulos
vermelhos aumento da próstata entendeu
tem que analisar o conjunto aí já vira a
consulta
né thago
pode fazer uso contínuo ou prolongado de
L teanina pode não tem problema nenhum
para relaxamento para redução de
estresse e e com uso mais prolongado a
eficácia pode diminuir não não diminui
Ok vários estudos mostraram que o uso da
lanina por até o semanas continua tendo
o mesmo efeito de redução de estresse e
relaxamento não tem nenhum tipo de
fenômeno de tolerância teve um estudo
que mostrou que a lanina não
aparentemente
tem tolerância ou efeito de dependência
é bem diferente da
cafeína Perina é muito segura e não tem
efeitos colaterais nas doses
habituais teve estudo humano mostrando a
eficácia e segurança de dos de 200 até
quase 1 g de LT anina por 8 semanas e
não teve nenhum problema continuou a ter
efeito antistress e relaxa
estudos de animais
também foram
semelhantes não tem tolerância nem
dependência tá então fica tranquilo
quanto a isso thago se você tá
assistindo ou se você vai assistir
depois né na versão
gravada na Live passada perguntei sobre
o cortisol bi idêntico e os efeitos
colaterais qual seria a razão pela qual
há efeitos colaterais mesmo sendo
bioidêntico veja bem uma coisa boa em
excesso se torna ruim não é porque é
bioidêntico que não existe dose alta não
teria sentido né se eu te dar para você
tomar 10 l de água de uma vez eu posso
te matar por hiponatremia
dilucional Então não é porque uma coisa
é boa que você pode dar a dose que você
quiser tá a diferença entre remédio e
veneno é a dose então mesmo sendo
idêntico Se você dá uma dose alta você
vai suprimir a suprarrenal ou adrenal e
essa pessoa vai ficar com problemas né
Ela pode ter vários efeitos colaterais
que seriam bem parecidos com efeitos
colaterais de Prednisona que é um
corticoide que não é bioidêntico o
corticoide sintético não é porque
bioidêntico que não existe
dose infinita todas as doses vão ser
boas
Ok próxima pergunta pergunta
Marilda Qual que é a dosagem ideal de
citrato de magnésio para rins Geralmente
eu utilizo entre 200 a 500 mg Ok por
dia é uma dose segura considerando a
magnésio elementar aí que eu tô falando
ok é bom para evitar cálculo renal né
magnésio é muito bom para evitar e
precipitação de cristais e formação de
pedra de cálculo
Eliane Existe alguma vantagem na
suplementação de alho negro sim o alho
negro é mais potente do que o alho
normal o óleo negro ele tem um efeito
mais poderoso na saúde cardiovascular
ele vai ajudar mais na saúde das
artérias na saúde do coração tem efeito
antioxidante antiinflamatório mais
potente tá o óleo negro é óo negro é
como se fosse um alo concentrado é um
alo que tem mais princípios
bioativos Eliane natoquinase picnogenol
EV mectina extrato de dente de leão nac
seria detox da vacina sim Nós criamos
essa fórmula para isso e da covid que
covid você tá falando covid longa ou
covid aguda Se for para covid longa
seria interessante também agora para
covid Agudo a gente usa outra
fórmula aí vai vitamina C que é cetina
Vitamina D
zinco então seria um pouquinho diferente
disso a EV mectina continua sendo
utilizada o nac também Nat kinas pode
ser utilizado mas essa fórmula aqui é
mais para complicações de longo prazo do
que para um tratamento de uma covid
aguda Você está acompanhando ao vivo
Eliane Depois eu vou ver as perguntas ao
vivo
tá próxima joelita ou ruel não sei se é
ruel ou joelita quais melhores
suplementos para quem tem fibrilação
arterial
paroxística bem é magnésio né é muito
importante para ajudar no ritmo cardíaco
ajuda a melhorar a pressão
arterial eh então É bem interessante
para tanto prevenir como para tratar aí
você pode usar o magnésio taurato pode
usar o magnésio orotato pode usar o
glicina pode usar o
magnésio também de malato
cozim que 10 que é uma substância muito
importante antioxidante para Metal
energia dá suporte à células musculares
do
coração e as doses comuns 100 a 200 mg
por
dia magnésio seria na faixa de 400 mg
por dia e tem o h Thorn né que é
é um vegetal muito interessante um
suplemento
herbário que tem efeito
anticoagulante e pode ajudar também no
ritmo sinusal em pessoas que têm
fibrilação paroxística tá então h
thornberry o tá eu não sei se tem nome
português mas é H Thorn que chama tá eu
sei que tá difícil deixa eu escrever
aqui na tela aqui senão vocês não vão
entender o que que eu tô falando aqui tá
o nome do suplemento É esse
aqui ômega3 também ajuda taurina também
ajuda taurina tem efeito interessante
pro
coração tá bom então são esses
principais Eliane É verdade que o T3
fica no organismo por apenas 6 horas sim
é verdade Iane casos positivos deveriam
repor Quantas vezes ao dia por questões
práticas Eliane eu sempre passo at três
duas vezes toma de manhã cedo e antes do
almoço poderia tomar uma terceira dose à
noite poderia só que eu não acho que os
maioria dos pacientes vai lembrar
Geralmente eu passo duas vezes ao dia em
Associação com T4 na maioria das vezes
então o T4 Dá Uma segurada também aí o
T4 é minha vida bem longa tem mais de um
dia de minha
vida
Antônio Renato a quantidade segura de
vinagre de maçã é de duas colheres de
sopa em 300 ml de água duas vezes ao dia
sim essa quantidade aí é bem segura
poderia até aumentar a dose vai depender
muito da tolerância gástrica da pessoa
se ela tem tolerância pode tomar mais do
que isso sim mas essa dose é bem segura
para grande maioria dos pacientes
tá
Silva Boa noite minha mãe tem diabetes
tdo médico ela vai recomendar tomar o
remédio qual remédio tá falando
metiformina
lifage outros você tá acima de 200 a
Glicemia imagino eu vinagre de maçã
ajuda ajuda sim a
controlar quais macas de berberina você
recomenda Eu geralmente manipulo tomando
manipular agora se você quer comprar na
internet
uma marca muito boa de berberina uma das
top é
a como é que é o nome eu comprei essa
marca outro
dia
therapeutics integrative therapeutics é
integrative
therapeutics uma marca muito boa de
beberina também Life extension outra
marca muito boa p encapsulations é outra
marca muito boa tá bom existe
contraindicação para beberina tem ela a
beberina pode dar problemas ela pode dar
diarreia cos espação gases T de estômago
flatulência tá é parecido com os efeitos
qu TR metiformina
e pode interagir com remédios
anticoagulantes então tomar cuidado com
isso se tiver tomando remédio
anticoagulante pode dar problema na
contagem de células brancas pode ter
risco aumentado de sangramento e pode
ter aumento do do rim também do fígado
nesse caso dor de cabeça tontura queda
de pressão arterial é possível como
efeitos
colaterais ter que tomar um certo
cuidado viu mas se você manter uma dose
de beberina na faixa de 500 a 1,5 g por
dia raramente dá efeito
colateral mas vai aumentando aos
pouquinhos começa com 500 mg vai
subindo dor Renato vou fazer
colonoscopia o médico vai usar midaz ulã
e fentanil sedação endovenosa você tem
alguma contraindicação não se for para
fazer só uma sedação para uma colona não
vecho problema nenhum outra coisa
mesmo se você não pode também interferir
nisso né se você falar para eles que não
vai aceitar eles não vão fazer então eu
não vejo nenhum sentido nisso
aí até porque é uma vez só que ela vai
tomar se fosse para tomar todo dia D
problema ok
mas não é o caso é só uma vez eu acho
que não vai dar nenhum problema Ton Fica
tranquilo quanto a isso
tá Silva câncer de colo de estômago
E aí repeti o estômago deve tá querendo
dizer outro L pâncreas é alimento de quê
eu acho que tá querendo dizer o que aqui
tá querendo dizer aquela aquela história
do Câncer se alimentar de glicose
Infelizmente eu aprendi isso com l
Ribeiro
essa história
aíí e acho que faria muito sentido o
efeito
warberg que a célula cancerígena Desliga
a mitocôndria só faz glicólise
anaeróbica Só que infelizmente
apareceram os estudos aí questionando
essa história viu
então Infelizmente existem células
tumorais sim que se alimentam de derivad
das gorduras não é não é verdade que
todo o câncer só vai se alimentar de
glicose eu gostaria que fosse verdade
mas tem um estudos mostrando que não é
bem assim
tá isso não deve ser considerado como um
mantra ah toda célula cancerígena só vai
se alimentar de glicose se eu tirar a
glicose da célula ela morre não é bem
assim pessoal é lógico que uma dieta
cetogênica ajuda mas sozinha ela não vai
resolver tá gostaria que fosse assim mas
a realidade é um pouco
diferente jejum intermitente é capaz de
parar crescimento de células
cancerígenas sim tem estudos mostrando
tanto em células culturas celulares e
animais que ciclos de jejum podem
reduzir o crescimento moral e tornar as
células mais sensíveis à
quimioterapia
então tem também estudos em humanos
estudos de caso controle que o jejum
durante quimioterapia reduz os os
efeitos colaterais
e ajudam no efeito da quimioterapia
aumentar a potência da
quimioterapia Isso também funciona para
algumas dietas que imitam o jejum
intermitente que aquela dieta do Walter
longo que é o fast mimicking
diet
ok Por que que isso Funciona porque o
jejum reduz a glicose o fator de
crescimento o
igf1 então isso ajuda na questão de
controlar o tumor a aumento da acetonas
também
ajuda pancreatite tem cura sim tem cura
e o pâncreas consegue se recuperar se a
pancreatite não for intensa suficiente
intensa demais e a pessoa fizer o
tratamento de suporte adequado né com
jejum com hidratação venosa
né então com esse tipo de suporte
hospitalar junto com o jejum o pâncreas
consegue se recuperar sim e tô
imaginando tá falando de pancreatite
aguda né porque a crônica ela se
desenvolve Depois de várias crises de
pancreatite aguda
mal curadas
tá café e problemas
intestinais o café sim em excesso ele
ele pode irritar o intestino provocar
diarreia e pode piorar uma pessoa que
tem intestino irritável Ok em excesso
agora café tomado até umas duas xícaras
por dia não é
prejudicial quais são os riscos da
colonoscopia pode perfurar intestino
grosso mas é raro Qual o melhor médico
para analisar o laudo o próprio médico
pediu Mas aí
seria o médico mais preparado seria o
coloproctologista ou
gastroenterologista depende da
capacidade de cada um tá se for dois
excelentes um excelente gastro um
excelente procto eu escolheria um
excelente procto mas geralmente isso não
é uma um fator relevante não
ok
Antônio Renato limão vinagre de maçã e
azeito de oliva quebra jejum não não
quebra não quebra jejum não tem caloria
suficiente para quebrar o
jejum bem vamos para as perguntas ao
vivo agora deixa eu tirar
aqui
Elise eu pediu para escrever na tela o
assunto da Live da quinta-feira é esse
aí
dmso Estela beijo para você querida tá
acompanhando ao vivo a Estela fica
quietinha demais Estela tem que falar
mais tão inteligente tem que falar
mais o tratamento da micose de unha tem
que ser feito via oral também é ideal
que seja feito oral e tópico tá os dois
juntos tomar vi oral estatina ou
itraconazol ou até terbinafina e pode
fazer tópico antifúngico e também pode
usar os óleos essenciais tem vídeo sobre
isso no
canal Quais são os critérios para saber
se a dose da vitamina K2 que deve ser
administrada com D para cada 10.000 de V
Vina D bom usar 100 mic de K2
basicamente isso tá grosseiramente
falando vitamina A não é obrigatório
fazer junto não sei que você tenha
alguma deficiência de vitamina A mas se
for fazer eu faria uns 2000 unidades de
vitamina A junto tá
bom É a primeira vez que pergunto
Desculpe ter exagerado né aí tá o Eliseu
assim falando assim O Eliseu falando
assim sua
amadora esse daí passa qualquer um
Eliseu Eliseu mestre jedai das perguntas
infinitas certo Vamos lá
eh cadê
Aqui tá vendo aqui ó ameixa omeb é bom
para qu não conheço Eliseu vou ter que
estudar esse assunto não
conheço Eu também achava isso aqui
Eliseu Mas infelizmente a realidade não
é bem
essa quimioterapia eficaz sim o problema
da quimioterapia é a toxicidade né então
se fosse só para atingir só as células
tumorais seria ótimo problema que também
intoxica as células normais esse que o
grande problema da quinoterapia
quais suplementos você indica antes e
depois de ter picado pelo mqu da
dente é aqueles mesmo que eu indico para
covid vitamina C D que cetina zinco tá
lá no material Isso
aí até quantas gramas de ômega-3 seria
de seguro depende tá para falar para
todo mundo no universo eu diria três
cápsulas de ômega3 aí dando mais ou
menos 1 g por dia agora tem gente que
poderia tomar doses muito maiores com
segurança vai depender de cada caso
o que que o excesso de ômega-3 pode
causar hemorragia eh tem efeito
anticoagulante tá
alo consumir 5 mg de molato por dia uma
porção de bb12 é armazenado pelo
corpo não miol é B9 não é B12
tá B12 das vitaminas do complexo B A
única que tem armazenamento as outras
não têm armazenamento tá Inclusive a B9
com molato não tem armazenamento
vitamina D
desculp vitamina D de 36 Qual a dose
seguro para aumentar até 80
depende Depende de muita coisa isso daí
Antônio eu tomaria 10.000 por dia se
atingir 70 eu reduziria para 5.000 por
dia o azeite de oliva não quebra quebra
o jejum sim mas a a gente tem um
conceito de jejum metabólico O que quer
dizer isso que o uma de oliva não tem
carboidrato nenhum ele não vai subir a
glicose e não vai subir a insulina então
Apesar dele tá dando caloria tá
quebrando o jejum de certa forma ele não
tá quebrando o jejum no sentido
metabólico de de subir o a glicose a
insulina tá
bom gente tem 45 minutos de
Live eu vou ficar mais 5 minutos e nós
vamos encerrar
Ok até para dar tempo de vocês que estão
ao vivo
eh eh perguntar alguma coisa aí do que
eu respondi dos
documentos estou achando que com uma
micose na unha que estou com micose na
unha porque ela está com uma mancha
parei de pintar estou usando h de deve
ser o TT né que é o
melaleuca T Tree que ela quis colocar em
inglês mas saiu tel Tree mas é o del
le que mais pessoal vamos aí V vou dar
tá com 46 quase 47 minutos eu vou ficar
até 50 minutos
OK Até porque vocês estão ouvindo minha
voz de Pato hoje
né semana que vem vou est Zerado Com
certeza amanhã já vou est bem melhor
Hoje eu tô me sentindo muito melhor que
tava assistindo ontem né
então eu acho que eu fiquei assim porque
eu fui malhar muito tarde da noite tava
muito quente de repente o tempo virou
muito rápido aqui em São Paulo e eu
malhando 10 11 horas da noite fazendo
muito aeróbico acho que a minha
imunidade
caiu então juntou mudança de clima com
exercício
aeróbico pouquinho talvez acima do que
eu tô
condicionado pessoal 2 minutos para
encerrar se tiver Pergunta aí Aproveita
porque senão só semana que
vem o cheiro da chuva causa gripe que eu
saiba não
Antônio a minha avó não falava isso não
viu que eu saiba não tem nada a ver
não na verdade o problema aqui foi o
choque térmico tava 30 e poucos graus
direto não tava aguentando dormir
direito inclusive mandei instalar ar
condicionado tava muito quente aí de
repente pu elor caiu do
nada e eu tava malhando meio tarde da
noite acho que foi é uma combinação de
fatores incl tô tomando vitamina C
altíssimas doses aqui para cortar logo
esse
troço bem acho que eu vou encerrar aqui
não tem mais perguntas falta um minuto
para
encerrar
te agradeço aí o comentário que bom que
pude
ajudar cheiro da chuva é o Vento Sul Não
entendi essa pergunta Não
genise obrigado antô Já tô
melhorando
obrigado
Obrigado Eliane Obrigado pelo
comentário bem pessoal agradeço muito a
presença de
vocês nós nos vemos na semana que vem na
próxima Live sem V
pato essa aqui ô Fernanda
é da fdc foi que a minha mulher achou na
farmácia tá se eu fosse escolher eu
pegaria Life extens Mas aí tem que
importar não ia eu tinha uma porrada que
também ncer Life extension em casa mas
foi acabando aos poucos mas ess que é
uma barca até razoável viu uma marca
americana Mas ela tá
nacionalizada Tchau pessoal até a semana
que vem um abraço para
vocês